SPEAKER: TensorFlow
Debugger, or TFDBG,
is a specialized runtime
debugger for TensorFlow.
Using the TensorFlow
debugger, you
can debug any
running competition
graphs in TensorFlow with
only two lines of code change.
This is difficult to achieve
with general debuggers,
such as GDB or Python's PDB.
In this video, we're
demonstrating the command line
interface of TensorFlow
Debugger, which
provides easy access
to the structure
and the intermediate states
of a running TensorFlow graph.
Here, I'm running a sample
code from our tutorials.
You can find a link to that
tutorial in the description.
For example, the
interface presents a list
of intermediate
tensors generated
during the previous
session.run call.
You can click node info to
view the type, attributes,
and other information
about the graph node
from which the
text was generated.
To look at the
structure of the graph
you can click list
inputs or list outputs.
Those will show the transitive
inbound or outbound tensors
of the given node.
You can also use the
conditional breakpoints feature
of the debugger to let the code
run until a certain condition
is satisfied on the graph.
For example, in this case
we will let the model run
until problematic values, such
as infinities and NaNs, or not
a number, appear in the graph.
Once the conditional
breakpoint is hit,
the interface presents
all the tensors
that contain the
infinities and NaNs
in a temporarily sorted order.
So you can see that
the tensor on the top
is the culprit tensor, namely,
the tensor that first produced
the infinities or NaNs.
You can click the
tensor to see its value
and use regular
expression search
to locate the indices of
the infinities and NaNs.
The TensorFlow
Debugger also allows
you to step through
nodes of the graph one
by one, in a way
that is analogous
to procedural language
debuggers such as GDB and PDB.
To step through
nodes of the graph,
we can use the command
S, which stands
for step, as we are doing here.
While you're stepping
through the graph
you can use the command Inject
to modify the value of a given
tensor while preserving the
values of all the other tensors
in a graph.
After the value injection, you
can keep stepping in the graph.
The stepping mode can be a
powerful tool for diagnosing
certain motor issues.
For example, if you suspect
that a specific tensor,
like a high learning
rate or a certain weight
causes issues in a
specific run, you
can change its value while
leaving all other tensors
untouched, and observe
the difference it makes.
To get started with
TensorFlow Debugger,
please check out the
links in the description.
Thanks very much.